بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
من قطر
من بلاد العرب ارحب بالجميع في بطوله كاس
العالم 2022
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم في اول مونديال ينظم في الشرق
الاوسط انطلاق بطوله كاس العالم قطر 2022
مع حفل الافتتاح والمباراه الاولى التي
تجمع بين قطر والاكوادور على ملعب البيت
بمدينه الخور اللجنه المنظمه والفيفا
تاكدان الجوزيه تامه للحدث وانه مناسبه
للتعايش بين الشعوب وتعزيز انتشار ثقافه
كره القدم عالميه
تركيا تعلن وشن عمليه عسكريه شماليه سوريا
والعراق وتقول انها اسفلت عن تدمير نحو 90
هدفا لحزب العمال الكردستاني وحلفاءه
قصاصا لما وصفته انقر بالهجوم الغادر في
اشاره الى الانفجار الذي وقع في اسطنبول
وادى الى سقوط قتلى وجرحى
مع احتلال معارك باقليم
القوات الاوكرانيه
ومواصله الاستفزازات لخلق تهديدا بوقوع
كارثه في المحطه والمدير العام للوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه يقول نقصا المحطه
غير مقبول ويجب ان يتوقف داعيا اطراف
في اليوم العالمي للطفل 49 طفله فلسطينيه
استشهدوا منذ بدايه العام الحالي منهم 32
طفلا في الضفه الغربيه و 17 في قطاع غزه
ليصل العدد الكلي للاطفال الشهداء منذ عام
2000 وحتى الان الى 220 طفلا بحسب الحركه
العالميه للدفاع عن العطف
الى اللقاء